Now I want to talk about two more ideas.
Recall when I had the centers
[INAUDIBLE] a frog,
I said let's focus on the verb formula.
That was indeed correct, but
one can have frames for nouns as well.
So one could have a frame for
Angela, or for lasagna, or for
Olive Garden, or for night.
If one had a frame for Angela and
lasagna, and so on, in that case,
one could, instead of saying Angela
here, point to a frame for Angela.
Here is an illustration
that shows you that.
We may have then
information about Angela,
quite apart from the sentence about
Angela having lasagna with her dad.
And that information might be pulled
together, with this frame for
ate to the pointer.
So that now this frame for ate is
connected with this frame for Angela.
Similarly we may have some information
for the restaurant of Olive Garden.
We may know for example, that
the Olive Garden is located in Atlanta,
or that it has a particular price range.
So, two ideas.
First, not only frames for
words, but also for nouns, and
second frames can get
connected with each other, so
that the filler of a slot in one frame,
can point to another frame.
So Ashok [sp?] it sounds like this kind
of representation can be used to make
even more advanced inferences.
So if I have a frame for
Angela, my frame for
Angela might have a slot
that says food preferences.
And under that food preference slot,
the filler might be Italian food.
And then, when I see this
representation, based on that slot and
that filler, I can then infer
that she's not only happy,
she's very happy because she
had one of her favorite foods.
>> That's a good point, David.
So far we have been talking about
sentence level understanding.
The sentence that Angela ate lasagna at
Olive Garden with her dad, for example.
But we can also talk about this
cost level understanding, or
this cost may contain a series of
sentences, one after the other.
So the first sentence, for instance,
may say something about Angela and
her food preferences.
And we may construct a frame for Angela.
The second sentence may say something
about, a restaurant called Olive Garden,
which is located in Atlanta.
And we may construct a frame for
the Olive Garden.
When the third sentence comes, and
says that Angela had lasagna
with her dad at Olive Garden,
we construct a frame, and then we
can hook up these various frames.
And now we beginning to get
a disclosed level understanding.
Not just a sentence level understanding.
So indeed, just like a frame enables
us to understand some unit of language.
For example, a sentence or a phrase.
When we start hooking up these frames
together, we can start understanding
larger units of language, for example,
a group of sentences of discourse.
As we go along, we will see these
frames also allow us to pull
information from the input sentences,
to put in the [INAUDIBLE] of this slot.
So indeed, the ability to hook these
frames together, allows for a lot
of complex inferences and they will be
a major part of common sense reasoning,
as we continue with this course.